wie sollen wir mit ungeimpften umgehen
nicht nur im spitzensport sondern
überall die große frage auch in der
deutschen politik mit der impfpflicht
auf keinen fall haben uns alle top
politiker monate lang versichert aber im
dezember dann die große wende ja also
olaf scholz damals noch gar nicht kann
ganz kanzler hierbei bild hat er die
impfpflicht angekündigt
und wir müssen dafür sorge tragen dass
wir auch einrichtungs bezogen eine
impfpflicht durchsetzen für die dortigen
beschäftigten der deutschen bundestag
ist da auf dem weg ich selber hat gesagt
was wir auch noch brauchen ist dass wir
ein gesetzgebungsverfahren auf den weg
bringen nur jeder abgeordnete nach
seinem gewissen abstimmt über eine
allgemeine impfpflicht mein vorschlag
ist dass wir nicht als regierung agieren
weil das eine gewissensfrage ist sondern
dass hier aus dem kreis der abgeordneten
heraus ein antrag im deutschen bundestag
eingebracht wird oder verschiedene
anträge die genau das regeln wann wir
eingebracht ich gehe davon aus dass es
noch dieses jahr losgeht denn meine idee
mein vorschlag ist ja dass der zeitpunkt
bis zu dem dann jeder und jede sich hat
impfen lassen auch nicht allzu fern
liegt also mein vorschlag anfang februar
oder anfang märz und das heißt es muss
auch jetzt beim losgehen ja das war ein
interview als november und ja jetzt ist
januar und die impfpflicht die wackelt
plötzlich bei uns im studio philippe
piatti unser bild meinungs- chef und wir
fragen uns philipp warum wackelt die
impfpflicht das klein ja immer noch sehr
konkret ja wie man gesehen hat konnte
ist der ampel regierung damals wirklich
nicht schnell genug gehen als olaf
scholz das angekündigt hat war er noch
nicht einmal kanzler als er hierbei bild
läufer und über die impfpflicht
gesprochen hat und hat gesagt noch
dieses jahr soll es losgehen heißt
kommen die anträge und für den anträgen
ist bislang einfach nichts zu sehen die
sind nicht da und die bundestagsdebatte
über die impfpflicht die wurde erst mal
schön verschoben richtung januar weil es
daran ganz erhebliche zweifel gibt und
zwar einerseits natürlich bürokratisch
wie macht man das eigentlich wie setzt
man das durch bestraft man die menschen
die sich nicht impfen lassen woher weiß
man überhaupt wer geimpft ist dazu
bräuchte es ein nationales register das
will man sich natürlich nicht antun und
man will natürlich auch nicht die
polizei losschicken damit ungeimpfte in
beugehaft genommen werden oder sonst
irgendwie mit physischer gewalt
gezwungen werden sich impfen zu lassen
das will man alles nicht und es gibt
natürlich auch noch den
wissenschaftlichen aspekt über den
gesprächen werden ja lass uns über
diesen sprechen denn fakt ist es gibt
erhebliche zweifel ob der
durchsetzbarkeit einer solchen pflicht
also die anträge im bundestag die sind
gerade dabei formuliert zu werden aber
immer kommen neue hürden raus und markus
söder hat ja gerade hier im bild live
interview auch gesagt der zeitplan erst
im märz der ist aus seiner sicht kaum
noch zu halten er ist tief verunsichert
sagt er und sagt man olaf scholz der
kanzler meint er natürlich auch
strategisch politisch aber der muss
jetzt mal in die gänge kommen die
regierung muss sich dessen annehmen und
eine impfpflicht gesetz formulieren lass
uns über diese wissenschaftlichen
bedenken daran sprechen also offenbar
gibt es probleme klar zu machen wie
viele impfungen denn diese impfpflicht
umfassen muss eine 234 möglicherweise
absolut das muss man sich mal vorstellen
da sitzen gerade abgeordnete eine von
den abgeordneten ist unser
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach
formulieren anträge zu einer impfung
über die fast jeden tag neue studien
reinkommen und man erfährt jeden tag
etwas neues darüber wie wirksam sie
beispielsweise ist es gab jetzt gerade
eben erst eine dänische studie die hat
verglichen wie ist das denn bei omikron
wie ist es für ungeimpfte für doppelt
geimpfte und für gepolsterte menschen
und dann kam raus dass es bei doppelt
geimpften und bei ungeimpften menschen
überhaupt keinen unterschied mehr gibt
ob man sich ansteckt oder nicht also
kein wort zu den schweren verläufen klar
die impfung schützt weiterhin zumindest
für eine zeit für schwere verläufe aber
man merkt die wirkung des impfstoffs ist
nicht ganz so gut wie man es vor einigen
monaten noch vermutet und gehofft hat
gerade jetzt nicht mit der omicron
variante das heißt man muss sich ständig
nach impfen also beschließt man nicht
nur eine impfpflicht dann soll eine
impfpflicht
und da hat das hat johann justizminister
marco buschmann schon gesagt wenn der
impfstoff dann nur für zwei bis drei
monate richtig wirkt dann spricht das
natürlich gegen die impfpflicht und aber
so sieht das aus das sagen gerade alles
studien die ersten zwei drei monate es
eine sehr starke wirkung zu auch gegen
schwere verläufe und dann mache ich seit
drei monaten gesagt wird aktuell ganz
genau spätestens drei monaten nachwuchs
wie kann man das überhaupt auflösen es
ist ja auch etwas was eben gerade wird
markus söder gesprochen haben das
problem dass eben immer neue varianten
kommen könnten die impfstoffe angepasst
werden können weil man die wirkstatt
wirksamkeit den vorher natürlich nicht
weiß das heißt da geht es sind immer
wieder ein arbeitsprozess an und das
könnt wie du sagst gesagt hast in einem
55 also das führt dazu dass menschen
sich natürlich jeden monat oder jeder
alle monate in einem regelmäßigen
abstand wieder neu impfen lassen das
kann man ja gar nicht fassen also rein
logisch kann es ja nicht einfachen ja
die impfpflicht gilt jetzt unendlich
also damit bedeutet das ende offen so
oft müssen sie an die nadel der muss ja
und das sagte er auf der
ministerpräsident kann es richtig
irgendeiner art rahmen irgendetwas
gefunden werden dass man auch nach außen
transportiert so hast du das gefühl man
kann sich da überhaupt auf irgendetwas
einigen und wenn ja dann glaubst du
könnte das überhaupt selbst dann sein
also ehrlich gesagt mein gefühl ist dass
einige kräfte innerhalb der ampel die
bis vor kurzem noch sehr für die
impfpflicht waren als die zahlen hier in
deutschland hoch geschnellt sind als die
intensiv spiel intensivstation voller
wurden als der politische druck höher
wurde zu handeln da haben einige leute
gesagt jetzt bin ich doch dafür und
gerade merken sie bei allem was man
jetzt über die mildere omikron variante
liest und hört
vielleicht war das doch nicht so richtig
wie heißt du die fdp die heute ihr
großes dreikönigstreffen hat oder auch
in der spd die fdp ganz sicher
wenn marco buschmann sagt wenn der
impfstoff nur zwei drei monate wirkt
dann macht das keinen sinn mit der
impfpflicht das ist ja das hört sich an
so als würde er sagen wenn sich das
herausstellt aber das sind die studien
sagen dass ja das heißt man sucht glaube
ich argumente um dann doch davon runter
zu kommen zumindest von der ganz große
den ganz großen hammer der allgemeine
impfpflicht aber wir wissen dass es auch
in der spd selbst große groß zweifel
gibt und ehrlich gesagt wenn man sich
die studien an schaut alles was jetzt
gerade raus kommt über den impfstoff
über die omikron variante spricht eher
gegen eine allgemeine impfpflicht
wackelt sagt unser bild meinem chef
philipp ii